ich habe überhaupt gar keine möglichkeit
gehabt mit zu sehr außer diese ideologie
anzunehmen dieser eine moment lässt sich
dann zu einem schluss zu kommen bleibt
ihr bringe dich um wenn jemand im verzug
trainer ist er hatte er bereits schon
eine reihe von straftaten begangen wenn
es jetzt wirklich zurück gucke ist das
der beste platz um menschen zu
manipulieren
weil das klientel sich die sich anbietet
sich gut eignen dafür
ich wusste da nicht mal was eine
radikalisierung ist ich wusste noch
nicht einmal das ist sowas gibt ich
wusste zwar wenn ich einen menschen töte
was ich damit anrichtet
aber das sagen doch die anderen kuh
vorbild mattierten und nun ist die frage
bewegt die menschen dort auf dann
verändert sich nichts oder versuche ich
ein angebot zu machen das sie über sich
selber noch mal nachdenken kann wenn man
hass hat dann ist man eine tickende
bombe
[Musik]